noch keine chance für corona lockerungen
sagt der gesundheitsminister und macht
hoffnung auf zusätzliche impfdosen rexit
deal abgesegnet das britische unterhaus
stimmt mit großer mehrheit für das eu
handelsabkommen auch die eu führung hat
unterzeichnet sturm auf den handball
thron der thw kiel gewinnt das finale
der champions league gegen den fc
barcelona
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
vorletzten tag des jahres den sport in
der sendung präsentiert norbert einen
stimmenanteil von mir mehr als 1100
coruna tote werden heute gemeldet das
ist erschreckend auch wenn darunter wohl
nach meldungen der feiertage sind
entsprechend eindringlich appelliert der
gesundheitsminister an alle auch an
silvester auf kontakte zu verzichten was
morgen passiere sei entscheidend für den
weiteren verlauf entscheidend sind auch
die impfungen und da kritisieren einige
bundesländer der bund liefere zu wenig
und zu langsam
britta spiekermann politik und
wissenschaft es ist die letzte
pressekonferenz dieser art im pandemie
jahr 2020 einsparen mit vielen fragen im
rücken steht er mit dem rücken zur wand
heute die meldung der
impfstoffhersteller biontech liefere
später als geplant alles im grünen
bereich sagt das ministerium der
impfstoff komme die spd spricht von
chaos zum impfstart der minister fordert
geduld
es ist auf jeden fall ein schwarzer tag
1129 todesfälle sind allein an diesem
morgen zu beklagen 1129 familien werden
diesen jahreswechsel in trauer erleben
diese zahlen belegen wie brutal dieses
virus immer noch zuschlägt die
infektions und todeszahlen zeigen aber
auch dass wir von einer normalität wie
wir sie uns wünschen noch sehr weit
entfernt sind also wohl keine
lockerungen nach dem zehnten januar
doch wie erklären sich die höchsten
todeszahlen seit beginn der pandemie
selbst der chef des robert
koch-instituts muss spekulieren
wenn sie sich die zahlen über die
feiertage anschauen dann waren alle
zahlen relativ gering sowohl die
fallzahlen als auch die übermittelten
todesahnung die plausibelste erklärung
wäre dass es verzögerte
gelungen sind impfen sei der einzige weg
aus der pandemie die bisher
registrierten nebenwirkungen wie
übelkeit und muskelschmerz seien
weitestgehend unbedenklich das bei dem
personenkreis der jüngeren und
erwachsenen hier die heftigkeit und
intensität vielleicht etwas höher ist
als für sie von der influenza impfung
kommt aber ansonsten gibt es keine
auffälligkeiten
jens spahn erwartet für die nächste
woche die zulassung eines impfstoffs des
us-konzerns moderner und verspricht sich
eine baldige lieferung von bis zu zwei
millionen impfdosen das kalkül mehr
hersteller mehr impfstoff es ist ein
wettlauf gegen die zeit auf unsicherem
gelände die impfungen gegen das corona
virus haben begonnen zunächst für
besonders gefährdete zu dieser ersten
gruppe zählen bestimmtes medizinisches
personal und vor allem etwa 5,7
millionen menschen über 80 mobile impft
teams fahren derzeit senioren und
pflegeheime an die große mehrheit der
über 80 jährigen wohnt aber im eigenen
zuhause wie sie an impfungen kommen und
was mit denen passiert die nicht mehr
mobil sind zeigte anrufer marlies rath
ist gerade 80 geworden lebt allein in
köln
sie hofft möglichst schnell gegen das
corona virus geimpft zu werden nur wie
wann und wo ist ihr noch nicht ganz klar
weiß ich nicht ob ich da schon damit an
geschrieben werde oder ob ich da
irgendwo ein bisschen verloren
ich muss sehen ich muss mich selber
kümmern denke ich tatsächlich müssen
sich über 80 jährige selbst bemühen um
einen impftermin das geht telefonisch
über eine hotline über eine
online-plattform und in einigen
bundesländern sind auch persönliche
benachrichtigungen per brief geplant
insgesamt ist das verfahren für kritiker
deutlich zu kompliziert schon die
kontaktaufnahme zu allen im zentrum ist
sehr schwierig jedes bundesland macht da
was es will
und zurzeit gibt es gar keine tel
einige bundesländer nehmen jetzt eine
warteliste auf andere sagen rufen sie
doch bitte am anfang des nächsten jahres
an in den meisten ländern gilt über
80-jährige werden erst ab mitte januar
geimpft und nur in den impfzentren wie
aber dorthin kommen wenn man nicht mehr
mobil ist erst einmal ist es so dass ich
ein bisschen auch auf die solidarität in
der gesellschaft setze das heißt dass
jeder der einen alten menschen kennt ihr
vielleicht nicht mehr so selbstständig
ist ihm vielleicht auch hilft es sind
sicherlich auch überlegungen in den
impfzentren das heißt bei uns in den
kreis und kreisfreien städten
ob man auch hier und da über die
hilfsorganisation ein service anbietet
eine wirkliche lösung für
hunderttausende nicht nur viele menschen
über 80 gibt es noch nicht
was lief womöglich falsch im kampf gegen
korona bringt 2021 die wände stellen sie
ihre fragen an die virologin ulrike
protzer um 19 uhr 30 bei zdf heute live
über youtube facebook oder unsere app in
großbritannien breitet sich offenbar die
mutierte corona variante rasend schnell
aus wie schon gestern wurden heute mehr
als 50.000 neuinfektionen registriert
deshalb gilt nun in weiten teilen
englands die höchste warnstufe
betroffen sind drei viertel der
bevölkerung sie sollen zu hause bleiben
seit heute ist in großbritannien per
notfall zulassung ein weiterer impfstoff
bereit von der firma astrazeneca
das mittel ist laut studien weniger
wirksam als das von bayern tech weiser
dafür kann es bei kühlschrank
temperaturen gelagert werden und ist
günstiger und dann ist heute auch noch
ein historischer tag in großbritannien
nach schier endlosen verhandlungen wird
der black city heute besiegelt kurze
röcke 2016 stimmen die briten für den
austritt aus der eu es folgen jahrelange
verhandlungen diesen januar dumbreck cit
mit einjährige übergangsphase um die
beziehungen ab 2021 zu klären
und jetzt kurz vor knapp im eiltempo
die eu-spitze zu das britische unterhaus
nachher noch das oberhaus und die queen
all das binnen stunden andreas stamm
berichtet schnell weg damit nur keine
fragen zu lassen so wirkt es 1250 seiten
komplizierte handels materie zumindest
er habe sie gelesen so prämie johnson
nach seiner unterschrift um etwas wie
den vertrag über die künftigen
beziehungen mit der eu zu verstehen
brauchen abgeordnete normal monate doch
im unterhaus wird das zum halb
tagesgeschäft mit satter mehrheit 521
jahr 73 nein-stimmen das ende des
quälenden offiziellen ausstiegsprozesses
wir werden freundschaftlich verbundenen
nachbarn der beste freund und alliierte
den die eu haben kann
wir werden hand in hand arbeiten wenn
immer unsere interessen sich
überschneiden
ansonsten wird der souveräne wunsch der
briten aber gewahrt bleiben nur nach den
eigenen gesetzen und regeln zu leben
souveränität die ihren preis hat
abgeordnete aus den landesteilen
nordirland und schottland machen klar
der deal gefährdet die einheit des
vereinigten königreichs die größte
oppositionspartei stimmt dagegen
weitgehend zu allerdings zähneknirschend
ein dünner deal ist besser als keiner
den vertrag ablehnen würde tarif und
handelshemmnisse im warenverkehr mit der
eu bedeuten ab übermorgen lebensmittel
wurden teurer unternehmen bankrott gehen
die zusammenarbeit der
sicherheitsbehörden wäre gefährdet um
das zu verhindern hatten die spitzen der
eu schon am morgen den vertrag signiert
per militärflieger ging das werk nach
london wo am abend auch das oberhaus und
die queen zustimmen dürften endlich ende
mit dem elend praxis ein frommer wunsch
denn das gehandelt wird weitergehen
zwischen nachbarn deren neuer vertrag
viele fragen ungeklärt lässt diana
zimmermann in london bei allem unmut
jetzt über die details ohne diese last
minute abkommen dieses lastminute
abkommen wäre das drama ungleich größer
ja das wäre es tatsächlich gewesen das
chaos wäre größer gewesen der
wirtschaftliche schaden und auch der
politische die für beziehungen zur eu
während auf absehbare zeit vergiftet
gewesen
so gesehen ist dieser vertrag ein
riesiger politischer erfolg und boris
johnson genießt es mal für etwas
gefeiert zu werden
dieses versprechen den braig sie
zuliefen liefern hat er gehalten
nun aber sind die zweifel sehr groß ob
die zukunft die der premier als sehr
rosig verspricht wirklich so rosig sein
wird es ist einfach so dass der handel
mit der eu ab freitag komplizierter wird
und großbritannien ist durch die korona
krise aber jetzt auch durch den eu
austritt wirtschaftlich wirklich stark
belastet auch politisch das hat die
erbittert geführte debatte heute im
unterhaus ganz klar gezeigt hat der exit
gerade erst begonnen
die schotten wollen mehr denn je mit
diesem projekt rexit nichts zu tun haben
eine kleine aber wachsende mehrheit
fordert die unabhängigkeit vom
königreich und so kommt das nächste
drama bestimmt die einschätzung unserer
korrespondenten dankeschön werner
zimmermann ein durchbruch auch auf einer
anderen riesenbaustelle der eu das
investitionsabkommen mit china steht
nach fast sieben jahren verhandlungen
damit sollen europäische firmen besseren
zugang zum riesigen chinesischen
wachstumsmarkt bekommen nach den usa ist
china der zweitgrößte handelspartner der
eu
im vergangenen jahr gingen jeden tag
waren im wert von durchschnittlich 1,5
milliarden euro hin und her
anne gellinek berechnet sieben jahre
lang haben die eu und china über ein
investitionsabkommen verhandelt und
plötzlich geht es ganz schnell
video konferenz der eu spitzen mit dem
chinesischen präsidenten jean ping
kanzlerin merkel und dem französischen
staatschef makro eine grundsatzeinigung
steht china wird seinen bislang
abgeschotteten markt mit 1,4 milliarden
menschen weiter öffnen europäische
unternehmen bekommen einen besseren
zugang zum automobilsektor bei
telekommunikation medizintechnik und im
bankgeschäft
es bedeutet dass wir endlich mehr
rechtssicherheit bekommen wir haben die
situation dass viele
europäische unternehmen in china
benachteiligt sind in manchen sektoren
keine 100 prozent alleine firmen haben
dürfen sondern immer chinesische partner
mit an bord haben
im gegenzug dürfen chinesische firmen in
europas energiewirtschaft investieren
aber nur wenn europäische unternehmen in
der gleichen branche in china tätig
werden dürfen
gehakt hatten die verhandlungen lange
beim thema zwangsarbeit china solle in
der provinz shin young bis zu einer
million und uhren in arbeits und
umerziehungslager festhalten
nun verspricht die chinesische regierung
dauerhafte anstrengungen zu unternehmen
um zwangsarbeit abzuschaffen sanktionen
allerdings gibt es keine
aus dem europaparlament kommt heftige
kritik dass wir nicht mehr hinkriegen
sollen als den chinesen ein billiges
geschwätz abzuhandeln in puncto
zwangsarbeit wo die ganze welt in diesem
jahr erlebt hat wie brutal das ist wie
systematisch das praktiziert wird das
abkommen könne nicht alle probleme mit
china lösen geben die eu verhandler zu
wenn das europa parlament zustimmt kann
der vertrag im nächsten jahr
unterschrieben werden im jemen sind bei
einer explosion mindestens 20 menschen
getötet und mehr als 50 verletzt worden
die tat ereignete sich am flughafen der
stadt aden kurz zuvor war eine maschine
mit mitgliedern der gerade neu
gebildeten regierung gelangt
die vermutet die schiitische houthi
miliz hinter der explosion im jemen tobt
seit sechs jahren ein erbitterter
bürgerkrieg zwischen hutu rebellen
separatisten und der von saudi arabien
unterstützten regierung eine historische
entscheidung nach jahrelanger
emotionaler debatte argentinien hat
abtreibung legalisiert
vor dem parlamentsgebäude feierten
tausende frauen ausgelassen ihr recht
auf selbstbestimmung mit dem neuen
gesetz ist abtreibung bis zur 14
schwangerschaftswoche erlaubt die kirche
im heimatland von papst franziskus hatte
versucht das zu verhindern
argentinien ist jetzt das größte land
südamerikas in dem abtreibung nicht
verboten ist
zurück nach europa in norwegen hat ein
erdrutsch mehrere häuser weggerissen
mindestens zehn menschen wurden verletzt
helfer mussten hunderte anwohner in
sicherheit bringen mehr als 15 personen
werden noch vermisst
allerdings ist offen ob sie sich im
katastrophengebiet aufgehalten haben
wie und warum der boden absackte ist
noch unklar zuletzt hatte es in der
region sehr viel geregnet wie dringend
das klimaschutz braucht zeigt sich beim
blick aufs wetter es war wieder viel zu
warmen 2020 war das zweitwärmste jahr
seit beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen in
deutschland 10,4 grad
die durchschnittstemperatur alarmierend
sagt der deutsche wetterdienst es gab
zudem viel zu wenig regen so sondern
santina hat den überblick
mit ganz viel schnee und eisigen
temperaturen begann der dezember doch
damit war es schnell vorbei und mit
insgesamt drei grad wärmer als normal
war dann auch dieser monat beispielhaft
für das gesamte jahr insgesamt war 2020
deutlich zu warm und auch zu trocken
insbesondere in der vegetationszeit das
heißt von april bis oktober ist deutlich
zu wenig niederschlag gefallen
in kombination mit sehr viel
sonnenschein hat es zu einer
austrocknung der böden geführt wir
hatten das dritte jahr in folge wo wir
probleme hatten für die landwirtschaft
und auch für die wälder
die folgen des klimawandels zeigen sich
auch dieses jahr weltweit australien
erlebt im januar die schlimmsten
waldbrände in seiner geschichte als
folge der langen hitze und
trockenperiode enorme brände auch in
kalifornien und bei der arktis sprechen
experten von unfassbaren
temperaturabweichungen hinzu kommt ein
rekord bei den tropenstürmen 30 gab es
in diesem jahr eine folge der zu warmen
ozean und das besondere ist dass die
tropenstürme in kürzester zeit sich
intensivieren
von einem kleinen sturm werden sie zu
monster sturms der kategorie vier oder
fünf und das ist ein klares indiz dafür
dass die klimakrise eine große rolle
spielt der deutsche wetterdienst spricht
von erneut alarmierenden fakten in
diesem jahr mit längst alarmierenden
folgen der klimaschutz sei das gebot der
stunde
jetzt zum sport und euphorischen
randvollen nova der thw kiel ist zurück
auf europas fußball thron mit einer
bärenstarken leistung im champions
league finale gestern abend gegen den
spanischen serienmeister aus barcelona
33 zu 28 stand ist am ende zum vierten
mal gewinnen die kinder die königsklasse
glanzvolle krönung eines
außergewöhnlichen corona es kein
feierlicher empfang der handball helden
heute in kiel statt dessen lobeshymnen
schriftform auch auf thw coach philipp
gyaja der erste der als trainer und als
spieler mit demselben verein die
champions league gewonnen hat war ein
emotionaler moment ich freue mich riesig
für meine jungs vor dem 1 1 gegen
barcelona brachten eckberg mit acht
toren bester werfer seiner großen
weinhold und pickel der später noch zum
wertvollsten spieler gekürt wurde den
thw auf kurs im tor wehrte sich niklas
landin buchstäblich mit allen
körperteilen gegen die katalanische
weltklasse offensive ein triumph am ende
eines speziellen jahres der gefeiert
wird am besten irgendwann noch einmal
mit fans in der heimischen arena dagegen
aus der traum von der ersten deutschen
weltmeisterschaft shootingstar gabriel
clemens verliert sein achtelfinalmatch
und das war an dramatik nicht zu
überbieten sieben mal vergab der
saarländer die chance das spiel zu
entscheiden
knapp daneben ist auch vorbei dass wir
im achtelfinale wird für gabriel clemens
zu einer nervenschlacht sondergleichen
einfach werfen reihen werfen rein aber
er ging ein streit
das match der vergebenen chancen steht 3
zu 3 nach sätzen sieben mal hätte
clemens das spiel für sich entscheiden
können
rattay ski sein angstgegner verfehlt
sogar neunmal dann schafft der pole die
benötigte doppel 1 endlich wenn man so
viele mit staatsverband oder vergibt
dann genießt man heute nichts mehr
es wird ihnen zunächst wenig trösten
clemens ist nun immerhin bester
deutscher in der weltrangliste
das ist ja auch schon was
hochspannung auch bei der weltcup
abfahrt der männer im italienischen
bormio
der zweifache olympiasieger matthias
mayr aus österreich liegt mit ganz 0,04
sekunden vorsprung vor seinem
teamkollegen vincent kriechmayr der
wiederum war nur zwei
hundertstelsekunden schneller als der
schweizer urs krümel auf rang drei
bester dsv fahrer romed baumann auf
platz 14
das war es von mir gerne wären auf das
mittwochslotto die gewinnzahlen lauten 5
8 11 40 44 45 superzahl 9 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto von
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
wie das warme wetter morgen zu ende geht
erzählt gleich katja gefahr von uns war
es dass das heute journal um 10 mit
claus kleber
danke für ihr interesse in allen einen
schönen abend und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
warme wetter jahr 2020 geht für einige
morgen doch recht winterlich zu ende und
das liegt an dem tief julia das liegt
derzeit über der bretagne
es bringt aber schon jetzt in der nacht
den ersten schnee hier westlich des
rheins im hunsrück und in der eifel etwa
oberhalb von 200 bis 400 meter der
besten fällt etwas regen sonst ist es
auch mal klar dass bildet sich nebel
die temperaturen sinken auf 4 grad in
nordfriesland und über den schnee
flächen am alpenrand geht es bis -8 grad
runter der schnee von heute nacht zieht
dann morgen im laufe des tages weiter
ostwärts erreicht dann auch den spessart
die rhön und zum abend auch die
schwäbische alb
es können in den höheren lagen der
mittelgebirge durchaus an die zehn
zentimeter neuschnee zusammenkommen
es wird also gefährlich glatt auf den
straßen im westen ganz anders sieht es
im osten aus da scheint zum teil schön
die sonne zwischen sachsen und dem
alpenrand
die temperatur am morgen liegen zwischen
0 grad im westerzgebirge und 6 grad hier
am oberrhein und der neujahrstag bringt
noch etwas schnee
zwischen dem sauerland und der ostsee
und danach geht es im winter nicht
weiter guten rutsch